Eco, you think you would ever shave your beard ever?
I'd have to have a pretty good reason to.
What's, like, one good reason you would think? Like, if I joined a fire department and had to wear a respirator.
Okay. That's a specific reason.
Well, you you can't Is that gonna happen?
I mean, hey, Annie. Anything's possible.
If
this,
dismantling the proprietary mining empire doesn't work out, it might start fighting fires instead. Similar
similar,
strategy, I think. So Dude, let me tell you guys a quick tangent. Let me just jump right in. So I'm playing with outside with my kids.
This was, like, two
two or three days ago.
And then, like, my daughter's riding the bike and, like, my kid two of them are, like, riding scooters. And so I'm, like, you know, sweatpants
in all positions ready to go. You're in dad mode.
I'm in super dad mode. Dude, I see smoke coming out of my
neighbor across the street's house.
And it smelled. I was like, what the heck is going on? And then I kind of move over and I'm like, oh yeah, there's definitely something here. And so I'm across the street. I tell my kids, don't move. I go in there and, know, sure shit, like, like, you know, move is like you tap the the door handle. Luckily, it wasn't, like, hot. So then I open it up. The wall is on fire.
I'm starting yelling in. Yeah. Yeah. I'm like, hey. Anyone in here? And they're like, yeah. I'm like, holy smokes. I'm about to freaking fireman carry out somebody of this, like, house. He's like, no. No. No. Don't worry. I got this, like, little host thing. I'm like, dude. And I had 911 on the phone, by the way, at this time. So I'm like, here, ready to do this. Anyways, long story long, like, the
I won't say how that fire started because it was really, like, dumb.
But
but yeah. And so all my neighbors were like, I you're so brave. You went into the house. I'm like, dude, I hope you would come into my house if my freaking house was on fire. Come on. Yeah. That's not reassuring.
Wait. No. You have to tell us how the fire started.
The dude was moving in and was throwing cardboard into the freaking fire. He was like, I don't know how I was gonna get rid of these. I was just gonna throw it into the fireplace.
Everybody loves a good burn pile. Yeah.
The house. Especially in California.
Well Yeah. Luckily, I don't live in Florida. Or what? Like I don't know, man. You know, this is above my pay grade. But but luckily
and, like, I mean and then, you know, one of my neighbors was like, oh, it seems like it's overkill for these, like, three fire trucks and, like, ambulance to come and blah blah. I'm like, well, you know, in their defense,
because I was, like, thinking through it, I'm like, dude, they don't know what they're walking into. I was just like, hey. Yeah. There is a fire. I don't know if it seems like it's pretty contained right now. But, like, some of those, like, one but the one neighbor said that, like, his in law's house burnt down, like, two Christmases ago because of some fireplace issue, and it was just like a matchbox. You know? It just went kaput.
So Like the wall was on fire of the house? The wall up the up the above the fireplace was on fire. Not the whole wall, but above the fireplace. Like, when you walked
in, I was like, yeah. No bueno. You know? Like, quickly, it was like, no bueno.
And and then I heard the guy in the other room, like, yelling, and I'm like and I, like, looked back for my kids to make sure they're not running across the street and getting clobbered by a car. And so but luckily, was, like, neighbors that were like, watch your kids. I'm like, okay. I'm going in. I'm like, yeah.
Yeah. Wow. And this guy's renting the place?
Oh, I dude, I
while I'm doing the fireman's scary. Hey. Yeah. You rented or buy it? No.
I I thought you said he was renting the place. No. I think you guys you know? I think so. I didn't get into all the details. I was just like, I'm glad you're okay. Wow. That's incredible.
I've never been in a house fire, and I I'm a warranty. But Same with me. And so,
much respect. I mean, Josh used to be a firefighter. Like, he was telling me story. Like, the firefighters
are just, like,
thank god for them. Like Yeah. Straight up. I mean I've had Okay. Your job is, like, when you get a call, you're going into probably a potentially a one way situation.
You know? And it's like
I it's funny you bring this up. I was actually, like, just talking to Josh about this a couple days ago.
And Oh, really? He was asking me if I would ever be a firefighter. I'm like, dude, I don't I don't think so. I'm I'm all about, like, personal responsibility.
And, like, if if you get yourself into a fire, like, that's kind of on you. I'm not sure I'm going in after you.
Yeah. Well, I mean, but but
well,
sure. But with that said, there's just so many weird scenarios. Like, oh, your electrical line outside your house, like, got knocked over in a storm, and then that caught, like, this thing on fire. Then the next thing you know, your house is on fire. It's like Yeah. I mean, I I almost burnt my house down running too many miners in the basement.
Yeah. Come over and plug in a miner. You know? You don't know what can happen. Those
dang terrace.
But, guys, it this is so fun to to I I it's been a while, and I this is episode 100?
Yeah. One hundredth episode.
This is nuts. And, actually, this, like, brings us right to the,
let's see. We started this podcast in January
2023.
No way. 2023,
all of 2024, and this is our the very 2025
now. So this has been a solid three year run.
That's crazy. It took us three years to get to a 100 episodes.
So we're about,
what, fifty fifty six weeks behind schedule. But There you go.
Hey. We made it. Right. Time. Yeah. That's right. Right on time.
Well, man,
where should we jump into?
Actually, right before you hopped on the call, I I got,
about a 100 of these. Woah.
I got about a 100 of these added boards,
that allow for
the user let's see if I can get in focus. It allows for the user to communicate with, Antminer Hashboard via USB c
instead of the proprietary data connector.
So, yeah, I've got almost a 100 of these soldered together now, and I'm ready to to try powering them up and testing them,
flashing them with the appropriate firmware.
So question.
Who owns Antminer? What company?
Bitmain.
Who who's the CEO of Bitmain?
I don't know who it is now. It was who will be Jihan Wu?
Any story around Jihan? Are you, like you and him got a relationship going on or something?
Okay. So
scrolling through notifications
on
the
Two Fifty Six Foundation Twitter
account,
and I see
Jihan Wu
followed the Two Fifty Six Foundation.
And
I'm like, okay.
Another scammer. Great.
But I looked at the account pro the profile, and it actually was Jihan Woo. Like, a 158,000
followers,
blue check mark.
If you want fuck, go fuck your mother. What what what the line? The the one of the best lines ever.
If you want fuck, fuck your mother. We're
definitely not we're getting censored now, but, Gi hun woo. Yeah. Leave it to mister Huddl to bring the best out in everybody. Everybody. Yeah. Shout out to Justin.
Yeah. He was rep GiHon Woo was replying to mister Huddl when he said that. Oh, mister Huddl. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But yeah. So I thought that was very interesting. So,
you know, somewhere out there between our two and ten million listeners,
apparently, Jihan Woo is a fan of the two fifty six Foundation.
So
shout out to
Jihan Woo.
Bunch his mother if you want fuck.
So good. I love it. Classic line.
It really is. I mean, Bitcoin has all these classic lines. It's just so good.
But, yeah, it's kind of,
I was surprised to see that because
our
mission is to dismantle the proprietary mining empire that Jihon Woo built
by taking open source code
and
leveraging it to and and close sourcing it and leveraging it to build a multibillion dollar industry.
So,
man, that's a weird intersection to be in, but here we are.
Here we are. Hey, man. Gi hun. We got Bitcoin addresses on the 256foundation.org.
Send a few Bitcoin our way. No problem.
We'll make good use of it. Our our donation policy is money from anyone, influence from no one. So How how much for Iko to shave his beard?
Oh. You for 1 Bitcoin?
We we
I'm talked to him at length on this from episode one to, like, probably 42,
and then I stopped. Yeah.
He literally has no price, which is actually BS to me. He's like, no. I would never I'm like, okay. 10,000 Bitcoin?
You wouldn't shave your beard for 10,000? I mean, your beard can grow back. That is ludicrous.
That's the wrong reason.
10,000
Bitcoin, bro.
Shave your beard for 10,000 Bitcoin? Well, first of all, this is hypothetical
because no one's actually offering me 10,000 Bitcoin to shave their beard. But if g hop Send the Bitcoin over first, please. Yeah. Send the Bitcoin over, and then I'll I'll think about it. Or
we'll get, Rob
Hamilton to put it in,
one of those clever
contract Yeah. Script. Mini script contracts.
Yeah.
So
it's been actually kinda crazy, though, you know, in the last year, let's say.
The last eleven ish months. So
maybe we we go back down memory lane, and then kind of
talk about, like, what's to come in 2026?
Is that a good kinda Sure. Start? Yeah.
I mean, I'd like to hear why Tyler shaved his beard, or is this all leading up to that?
Well, Tyler's shaving his beard. That's why he was on mute because he feels like, you know, he he made a mistake, obviously. No. I'm on the exit. Because Eric's yelling downstairs for some reason, and I have glass walls in this building. But
I was I was we we had a call the other day. I was at a truck stop in Kansas with a rather fitting beard. Woah. And Rod Rod made a sly comment.
I shaved I shaved it.
You know what? You you know anything about lot lizards, Tyler?
A little bit.
Okay. We'll save that for another another conversation.
But
let's get back on the rails. The no. You looked good. It was, I think, a good look.
Too late.
It'll grow back. It'll grow back. Yeah. 100%. Give us the recap.
You're living room down.
So, dude, what I mean, Ico and Scott, because you guys were in it in it with me. What was your your thoughts
on the probability of us actually, a, hitting a block and then, b, funding
these projects, which we'll run through and and and provide an update to everybody?
Alright. So we're we're going back in time to to Like, January 1. In January. Right before the telahash. Yeah.
I you know, I'm thinking to myself,
there's a chance.
There's a nonzero chance.
All it takes is one hash,
and there's a chance we can we can hit that block.
And
if you wanna win, you've gotta gamble.
Remember our debate, by the way, of just taking the win
versus
actually
just going a lottery mining and just saying YOLO? I think I was in the camp of just, like, taking the money. Like, it was, like, a couple thousand bucks initially.
Yeah. You wanted to do, like, a like, point it to, like, a FPPS
pool account that we have. And then just you know?
Because it it sounded like we were gonna get the one x a hash.
Yep. At that point in time.
And
so
the option then was like, well, we could solo mine and take a chance
and and get, like, all or nothing,
or we can point it to a full pay per share pool account and get you know, I don't know what that would have come out to for a couple hours. Maybe,
like, another $5,000
worth of Bitcoin. Yeah. It was nothing. Once I knew the calculation, I was like, f that. Let's just go for it. Yeah.
Remember
the the morning of
in Nashville, I'm down the street at Sonder,
getting ready, listening to episodes of this pod to catch up
and hearing you talk about this. And I was like, this is crazy. What? They're gonna do what? Like, no.
And I'm like, well, it does sound that's Rod. I mean, that sounds like a Rod.
Was seriously.
And yeah. So, Scott, I'm curious to know your thoughts as well.
I feel like we had
several podcasts leading up to the event, which we were we were kinda talking about it. And I was like,
I was fully on the, like, YOLO,
just we gotta solo minus. We gotta solo minus. And you guys were like, well,
I don't know. I don't know. I feel like it wasn't
we hadn't fully decided or at least I wasn't aware that there was any And
then I showed up in Nashville and we were just getting ready. And I still wasn't aware of how this is gonna go down.
I don't know when the decision was made, but it just seemed like we were just rolling,
and we were solo mining. So the decision was made at some point. I think it was pretty close to the to the start.
Real.
Yeah. I mean, it it almost didn't happen at all because the
we were running the pool Mhmm. Off of a Futurebit Apollo
Mhmm. Which is, you know, for anyone who doesn't know, go to what's their website? Futurebit.com?
Futurebit.io,
I think. Okay. Futurebit.io.
And Yeah. You know, look at their devices. It's just it's like a small
computer or like a think of like a Raspberry Pi on steroids
that has a hash board in it as well. And so you're able to run a full node on it, and you're able to mine Bitcoin.
And
right before we had done the telehash
or shortly before we had done the telehash,
Futurebit had worked with doctor Khan Kolovus,
who developed CK Pool,
to
make it so that people who had a future Bit Apollo could run their own solo mining pool.
And so that's what we were doing.
And
we ended up getting, I think at the height of the event,
1.12
Exahash
pointed to that Apollo future bit.
And
and it handled it, and it it actually
resulted in in successfully mining a Bitcoin block. Block number 881423.
It was it was it was the first time I think anyone I mean, is hard to test, but it was the first time an Exahash had ever been pointed
at that software. Because
I remember as soon as the hash rate ramped up to over an exahash, it just reset to hash. Like, was showing like, you know, 1.1 hashes per second. Yeah. Yeah.
And interestingly,
the difficulty
did the same thing. After the difficulty was high enough to successfully mine a block, it it, like, rolled over.
It was like where we got the classic eco, like, wait. What?
It's fake. But so, yeah, there's there's though those, like, interfacing issues where you're, like, looking at the GUI and, like, not quite sure. Like, is are we really at one hash, or are we at, like, like, a a million terahash?
And then you're like,
there was also issues with the the stability of the future bit Apollo itself.
And so, like,
person who was donating an exahash to us would,
like, fire
a, you know, several 100 or even a couple thousand miners at a time to the mining pool that we had set up,
and it would cause the server to crash.
The Apollo would crash because
we had gone in and changed some things in the configuration files so that in the event that it mined a block, it would say two fifty six foundation in the Coinbase reward. Mhmm.
And I think when we were in there with that file,
we got some syntax wrong, and it, like,
that was that was one of the stability issues. And then there might have been something else. I think some other files got tampered with too. But,
I mean, it was up and down.
And, like, and touch and go, and, like, sometimes we would have, like, you'd see the hash rate ramping up, you know, like, 50 petahash,
100 petahash,
500 petahash,
800 petahash, and then all of sudden it would crash and reset to zero.
And
so the person who was working on getting the exahash
of their own miner's point, it was sitting in the room
on their laptop SSHed
into the Apollo, like, trying to work the back end to, like, get it running.
And they were in contact with John Stefanopoulos from Futurebit
who
you know, they're messaging back and forth to resolve the issues.
And,
yeah, I mean, they
they've
figured it out. We got over an exahash.
I think at the moment the block find occurred,
there was, like, 800 petahash pointed to the solar pool.
And the block was found by a miner that belonged to
Megawatt.
The guys at Megawatt.
In Indy.
Yep.
Yep. Just and they were there in in person
that night as well, which was just so surreal.
I mean, honestly, I'll never forget that night. I thought it was the I was like, this is the dumbest thing I've probably ever done in my life. I've done a lot of dumb things. I'm like, we just wasted seven hours here talking about all these projects, and it's gonna be, like, so difficult to fund. I I know how important they are, but, man, we need, like, a few $100,000,
and we only raised, like you know, Heatbit was massive. They came in. Foundry was massive. HRF was massive.
You know? But they were like it was like maybe maybe one project with their, like, funding. Yeah. And we and Eco,
his credit,
did looking back at that telehash,
I'm pretty sure that
MFR did not move out of that seat. And he just sat there and just was like, every single project was explaining every single project. He's like, alright. This is the next project. Mugena,
next project. Leapboard, next project. And down the list, HYDRA pool, next project.
And he was like, alright. Once we hit this block, you know,
we'll go. But I'll also never forget, Ryan,
when we did hit the block and you'd started and and also well, maybe before that, when Iko was explaining the Magina project, you're like, this
is right in my wheelhouse.
And then that night, we get an inbound
from you with this crappy type form we created. I don't know how you did it, but it was, like, nine paragraphs per response
of, like, in detail how you would, you know, work on the Mugena project, which I'll never forget.
Legend. Yeah. That was exciting.
That was exciting to be there.
Well, know how long I've lurked around Bitcoin Park like, yeah, I'll I'll find something to work on soon. Don't worry.
Yeah. There there was Ico,
his siren call,
nerd sniping
the audience.
So one of the things is, like and and and I know it's listed on the site, but we've basically deployed
of the we've deployed a little over $400,000
on these projects.
So which of the projects have been funded, ECO?
Well You wanna recap? So, yeah, after I mean, let's just do this in chronological order. So we've we've hit the block.
Yep. You know, got 3.14
Bitcoin or whatever it was.
So that was in addition to the supporters who had already given to the foundation.
And
and then we like, we were just flooded with
messages
through our through our website contact form and then through, like, the,
application
form, the type form for the grants themselves.
We had to, like, go in and, like, do the paid subscription for those services because we went over, like, our monthly allotment of responses,
in
hours.
So, yeah, we
you know, a lot of attention
from across the entire industry was on the two fifty six foundation.
And
we
were able to
sift through all the applications and the contacts we had got and
figure out who
we were you know, I we were able to identify who we thought was was gonna be a great
contributor to the project, and so we narrowed it down to a couple candidates per project.
And then we reached out to those individuals
and set up interviews
and just had a
you know, interview is too formal of a word, but, know, we had a conversation with the people that we were interested in working with just to get a better idea of who they were, how they approach things,
and, you know, what they what their thoughts were on the project because we needed each of them to drive their respective projects.
And,
you know, after those conversations,
you know, I it didn't take us very long to make up our minds on who we wanted to work with. And so then we reached out, and we found Ryan to work on the Mugena firmware project.
We had
Schnitzel to work on the Libre board, the control board project.
Scott was had already done
most of the work for
Ember one by that point.
I think by the time we started bringing in other candidates, Ember one might have the first Ember one cycle might have been right around the end of its first grant cycle. So
Scott had already you know, that was the very first project that we funded. And so Ember one was the hash board component,
and that was ahead of all the other projects. And then we had
identified Jungli to work on the HydroPool project,
which is the self hosted mining pool that anybody can run.
And
between those four projects, that's how we
figured,
we could open source the entire Bitcoin mining stack,
the whole technology stack.
Amazing.
And so
now
fast forward today, and I should maybe double clicking into Mugena. Ryan, do you wanna just provide your perspective on working on the project and where we're at with that?
Sure.
Well, it's been a
it's been a great three fourths of a year or whatever.
I
started out with a blank page, basically, but a bunch of reference projects.
So ESP Miner,
some stuff from
some great documentation online.
Scott helped me out, give credit to
who's this stuff I was looking at.
Nebula.
Nebula minor. Nebula's reverse engineer. One of these guys that just shows up, like, early on and is like,
I'm, you know, an expert in this field, and I'm
I'm all in. You know? Like, years ago I love it. Just contacted me. It was, like, all in and just did tons of work. Anyways, published some great documentation.
Yeah.
So standing on the shoulders of all that,
I've sort of put together
a modern
miner in Rust that runs on Linux.
Since we didn't have Ember one hardware
right away,
Scott and I came up with a way to use a BidX as
development hardware.
So,
you know, BidX normally runs with its own minor on board on its ESP 32 that's right on the board. We basically turned that into a pass through to the USB connector
so that it looks like just a hash board the same way that Ember one does.
And then I was able to use that, you know, as a stand in to develop software against initially.
So that's one of the things that,
because we're a little slower on getting the hardware, you know, that we planned on,
that's one of the things that works today, we just decided, oh, you know, that's going be more than development platform, we're just going to ship that, like, that's going to be an officially supported
board. So that's one of the things you can do with Mugena today, you download it,
is pair it up with a bit x gamma,
and use that as a hash board.
And then
we got a few fans, don't see him in the chat today.
But did Dylan do it on this. Right? Right, Tyler? Yeah. Yeah. We got one here running, Magina.
That was a
good idea, Ryan. I think we were we were talking about that, and you brought that up as, like, you know, if we wanna get people in early on this and hacking on it and investigating it and running it, you know, let's let's use a Bidax, which lots of people have.
You know? So it's like lower the barrier to to developing
and contributing to Mugena. I thought that was a fantastic idea.
Yeah.
Yeah. That was kind of leading up to saying that that very thing is, you know, we kind of just initially did it because that was convenient,
and then it was like, we might as well ship it. But the way it's turned out, yeah, I think
I mean, it is so easy. It will be so easy for anyone out there
to
grab Magena with or without a Bidaxe and just start hacking. It's it it it's it's gonna be a great entry level way to play with mining
or use an educational setting
or someone alone who just wants to tinker. You know? I mean, Ember one is a little
a little is more complicated than a BidX. It's bigger. It's more expensive. You need a power supply. You need to cool it.
Whereas BidX is just grab and go. So, yeah, that's that's kind of emerged as a first class,
way to tinker with this stuff. So that works, that's works today.
So
the year has been about, you know,
building up support for that, for Ember one. So I have an an early version of Ember one hardware here
that Magina works with.
And then
it should not be that hard as soon as we get Ember one v fives
off Eko's production line.
So what we're working toward now is
with the deadline of the Telehash in mind,
having
m r one v fives.
We've got several things in flight trying to have good demos for for Telehash.
So Yeah.
We've got
we just were on a call earlier today with Ryan Ramminger
of
Cryobyte.
Do I have that right, Tyler? Yeah. Cryobyte,
he he does all sorts of heat plates for,
you know, up till now, like industrial miners. He's working on a heat plate for
Ember one. We just got a preview of this morning.
It's so dope. I can't wait to show this off. It was Tyler was there with me. It's really cool. He's doing a bang up job.
Yeah. And that that's that's an important distinction to be making is that
Ember one is just the design of the hash board itself.
And so what we need to do with that hash board is
have a reference,
like, cooling device on it, whether that's like a like a air
like a cooling block that's cooled down with air
or like a cooling block like the one they're talking about that's cooled with water.
There needs to be some sort of, like, reference
cooling block for it.
There needs to be a reference power supply.
If we're going with air, there should be, like, a reference fan to go along with that block as well.
So there's you know, as once we get the hardware built, that's that's one piece of it, but we've gotta get that hardware into the hands of the community to start testing out different power supplies and fans and cooling methods to get that feedback
and and, you know, decide what the reference is gonna be that we recommend
to go along with the hardware.
Tyler, what's been your experience?
All this stuff.
My perception of it has been I'm already starting to see
the abstraction of all the components, the mining stack we just watched we just walked through. But even like Igo was saying with the heat sink and the water block,
you can really break these down into little Lego pieces of what makes up a Bitcoin miner, and I think the two fifty six Foundation, these projects
already are showcasing, like we've talked extensively that Mugena is more of an application. Right? You can run it on a Raspberry Pi. You can run it on a computer.
And so we've kind of, like, blown up this
closed black box already. Mhmm. And it's so cool what ideas start coming to mind when you're like Yeah. I need I grab this piece. I grab this piece. I I need these three at least to talk to each other, and I can build whatever the hell I want. And it's so exciting.
Yeah. Heck yeah.
Well, yeah, speaking of the Telehash, I can't wait to see you guys all in person in twenty one days, actually.
And it would be awesome because, like, you know, Iko, you did such a bang up job last year explaining the projects.
It'll be I I I know only person I don't think is coming is Jungling,
but, like, just basically showcasing
and looking at a retrospective
from each of the projects
as well as, hey.
Point us some hash rate, donate some stats, donate some dollars, whatever it may be. We wanna continue to fund these specific projects. We've got a lot of exciting updates to share, and we're gonna share them in person at the at the at the telehash.
And I
do think, like, the cat's out of the bag now, meaning, like, there's enough moment. We we still need more momentum, especially financially, as well as developers just continue to, you know, tinker and contribute to each of these projects.
But I'm cautiously optimistic
of where this is going, especially in 2026.
Yeah. We we wanna make this Telehash like a
pseudo
product launch
for everything that we've developed, you know, and showcase
all the stuff running.
So that's that's the plan is to have, like, a Ember one
talking to a
leaderboard
running Magena
with the whole Telehash pool itself running on Hydropool,
which I have the server sitting here on my desk.
That would be so cool. Yeah. That would just be so cool.
Yeah. Working on some hash rate. By the way, tangent into
do we have any hashers pointing us hash right now?
I'm sure. Let me pull it up. Let's go, Tyler.
Yeah. We we knock on wood. We have some good
hashers. Well, how about this? All the freaking
members at the park, every time I go into a little new nook and cranny, there's another bid axe running. And I'm like, these guys just
sniping
a little bit of electricity from the park to go and buy some blogs. Maybe I'm gonna go around and some cuts. I know. Exactly.
Exactly. It can't be that much.
Well,
if you I I count four in the main room.
I've got four sitting here on the shelf next to me right now.
And that nerd axe pulls quite a bit of juice, doesn't it? Think so. Yeah. I think that one's
isn't it, like, 50 watts or 60 watts?
Something like that.
I got the hashers up. Let's go, Tyler. I don't know if you've heard in a while, Rob, but there's some funny ones. Alright. Oh, tell me. On LingCoin, we got our OGs. We got schnitzel fish tank axe and Scott offered for Bitcoin mining world. Those two have been pointing us hash rate for a long time.
By the way, tangent.
Yeah. Schnitzel's coming back with the
Hashtub. Hot tub. Hashtub hot tub. Yeah. He's made quite some improvements, I've heard too. Oh, yeah? Anything that you can share?
It should be water cooled this year, so no messy immersion oil. Yeah. It's gonna be drastically simplified,
which is gonna be awesome.
Very cool.
Also have Merry Christmas Hashers. Here's to 100 episodes of two fifty six pod.
Let's go. Nice.
Thank you. Very fitting.
Merry Christmas,
especially to all the haters who are saying happy holidays.
There we go. Okay.
Tangent on this one. I do say Christmas, and I do
I say Merry Christmas.
But I say happy holidays, Merry Christmas, and happy New Year.
Too complicated.
No. I'm kidding.
You have to do the happy New Year. In this house, we say
shout out to Jeffrey Epstein did not kill himself on solo CK pool.
That one's here at Bitcoin Park.
Is it really? Oh, is it yours?
It's probably because
Yeah. I set that one up.
Doc. Wow. Okay. Have Schnitzel
Wall Axe One,
Woodminer Spitaxe,
Rock paper bitcoin.fm.
Yeah. Boring worker name,
Iko's favorite, which is Ocean Pool is centralized and custodial.
Alright.
Good action. By the way, Woodminer, real quick. He's coming to the NEMs,
and I probably will tell a hash. And, I mean, his story is just so amazing. I, like, gifted him a future bit, which he then took and then, like, started his whole journey. I believe that's the the case. So Yeah. There's so many of these little like, I I say to use the word little. They're just not even little. They're amazing stories of trajectory changing
where somebody experiences Bitcoin, they experience mining, they experience all these different facets,
and it just takes them into a whole another stratosphere. I mean, Tyler is a perfect example of that as
It's it's amazing.
It is.
Speaking on that,
I think this will be Iko's favorite hasher, actually.
Shout out on solo CK pool to bitcoingunshop.com
site live in January, selling guns and suppressors. Email hello at bitcoin gun shop dot com with what you want in stock on launch day.
Oh, wow. That is one packer message.
Yeah. That that is how you you you snipe in some clear advertising.
You gotta read that one again. Go ahead read that one again for everybody.
Alright.
Shout out to bitcoingunshop.com.
Site live in January. Selling guns and suppressors. Email hello at bitcoin gun shop dot com with what you want in stock on launch day.
It's coming up. It's coming up. I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to add a unit test for a long worker name like that because
Didn't Rob try to figure it out? It's pretty long.
Then BidX205.
Those those gun shop guys sent me a
DM.
Of course, they did. I thought they were sending you something else.
Just a DM.
Let's see. Yeah. So they've got a Twitter account. If anyone wants to go and follow at
bitcoin gun shop on Twitter,
they are getting set up.
Let me click into their profile here.
So, yeah, their profile says site will go live soon. We are a Bitcoin only
FFL,
so a federally licensed firearm dealer.
Hit us up for any firearm or silencing you need. All federal, state, local, and NFA laws
followed.
So there you go.
Nice. Hey. What was the the hasher's name that was, like, the Trump exposed or something? Oh. Oh. I
can't remember. Yeah. Oh, I don't know. We We
We need to go back, like, do a retrospective on all, like, the craziest, like, the top 10 craziest
hasher names. There should be, a leaderboard on the Yeah. 256 website.
Yeah. Just like here's
the the incognito window where you need a
Yeah. But
seriously, to all the hashers, really thankful. Like, it's awesome.
Whether it's one hash to an ex hash, it it means a lot. So thank you.
Yeah.
What what's the saying? Like,
each raindrop contributes to to making a massive storm,
Something like that.
Anybody? I like it. Okay. That was Mike Clear. He just came by by to say hello and gave me block of wood.
I like it. Let me finish here. So public pool
Oh, okay. That hardestblocks.org.
That's a great site. Hardestblocks.org?
Yeah.
That's a that's a cool one. Right? It's a it sorts all the blocks by the the best difficulty that's never been achieved. Like, these are the list of overachievers here in mining. It's pretty neat.
It's cool to see.
Yeah. Mugina Bitaxe Gamma. Is that you, Ryan?
I might know where that one is. Yeah. Nice.
Stalin's Bitaxe.
And finally here on Ocean,
we have Bible HODL,
Rekkles Systems, Geyser Fund Project, Satoshi Starter,
Pisandy Proof of Print, Bitaxe one,
servingbitcoin.com
two, You Stay Classy San Diego,
Serving bitcoin.com.
One, anything you type, Stevens will read.
Sarkasay Hash,
Western Mass, Bitcoin Meetup, and Bitaxe wannabe, just an S17 Pro. Let's go. Great. Serving Bitcoin is cool. Right? They are selling nodes. Right? They take and Yeah. Bought one. Refurbish
great.
Refurbish computers
and and set them up to Oh, really? Your own node. And what's site?
Serving Bitcoin.
Wait. Is that it?
Yes. Servingbitcoin.com.
Dotcom. Oh,.com. Okay. Yeah. Just little refurb like Lenovo.
I don't know. What are those? Like, mini desktops you'd see at a Oh, so elementary school or something? Yeah. It's a clean website.
They definitely
stole strategy's
logo, but it's okay.
It's similar to what I'm running HydroPool on here. I have an old Dell Optiplex desktop,
like one of those, like, small form factor computers.
Yeah. HydroPool's
slick, man. We we had a really simple time setting it up on our little Proxmox container.
Oh, that reminds me.
I
I think it was, like, the day before you posted your screenshot of your,
HydroPool dashboard,
Tyler.
I had
posted the step by step guide on how someone can do the exact setup I have for HydroPool
on hydropool.org.
So if you go to hydropool.org
and scroll down a little bit, you'll see like a step by step guide that details exactly how I set up the server I have running here at that
will be running the telehash on.
Sweet. So for any
tech
geeks out there that want to do this, I just I took an old Dell Optiplex ninety twenty.
I flashed it with Ubuntu server twenty four point zero four point three,
long term service.
And
the steps are pretty simple. You you need to install Docker, so that's covered in there.
You need to,
install Bitcoin Core. So I did that with the Snap
manager package manager.
And so all those steps are included. And then once you have Bitcoin Core
synchronized to the chain tip,
or you can use you can use any Bitcoin node software you want, anything that supports stratum or, RPC communication.
So you could for those of you running knots, you could do that if you wanted to.
I did I did my example with Bitcoin Core.
And then
it's basically just two commands to get HydroPool.
You just you get the
config file for HydroPool,
and the
config file for,
Prometheus
oh, sorry. Three commands and the config file for Docker.
And then if you wanna open it up to the public, there's like an extra step you take to,
like, generate a secure password
and put that into those three configuration files.
And
and then you're pretty much up and running. It's it's pretty simple and slick, and,
Jungly did a good job putting it all together.
Amazing.
As Scott would say, legend.
Jungly is a legend.
So alright.
Looking out to 2026,
I do think I love this, like, proof of work. Let's like, product demo at that at that this telehash as well as the future telehashes as well.
And by the way, I hope the, you know, Bitcoin veterans guys did a telehash,
you know, other folks, like, this is not a, February or Bitcoin Park ID. I mean, do your own telehash. It's freaking dope.
And if you wanna point the $2.56 foundation some hash rate, that's even cooler too. But, I love this idea of just, like, clubs and anyone
pointing hash rate to projects that they support.
It's it's it's amazing.
Yeah.
And it it works. Prove like, we proved it that the idea works. Unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
We're gonna make any
any,
expectations for,
another block?
Run it back?
That's a good question. We'll see. So we we did have a second telehash fundraiser in on Cinco de Mayo in Austin, Texas,
and we did not find a block at that telehash.
I was so bullish we were.
We're doing it. We're doing it. Megawatts still had the highest difficulty, which was awesome.
Yeah. Did. Yeah. Shout out to those guys for showing up for us.
And that was run on a prototype of HydroPool too, which was pretty neat.
Yeah.
By the way, for NEMs,
one or a couple of the guys and, Scott, thanks for connecting me with the Tethr team. Looks like they're coming to, the National Energy and Mining Summit and Telehash.
So
I know Paolo listens to every single episode of ours. Paolo Shout out. If you have some if you have some loose Bitcoin underneath your, you know, seat cushions or whatever,
put the Bitcoin to the side.
I hear you're getting into the you know, you got some hash rate. They they just bought, like, Peak Mining or something, you know, and some other miners.
Just point, like, a few extra hash our way. Just 100 extra hash, dude. Just a few. Yeah. 100. Yeah. Dude. You need just a big deal.
Let me help me help you Right. You know, here. Like, help me help you. It would be super dope. Like, if you wanna get to our audience of 10,000,000 plus folks two to 10,000,000 plus 10, plus folks,
easy way. Just snipe in.
We could offer to shave Ico's beard live on stage.
See,
I need guaranteed
Bitcoin. I need, like, minimum, like, a thousand Bitcoin because my guy got it has to we gotta clip off, like, a 100 minimum to eco to do this. How many hash rate how much hash rate do you need to, like, basically have a 100% odds in eight hours?
Go to solochance.com
and and What's the total hash rate right now?
I don't know. Over a Zetta hash, I think.
So I say one Zetta hash would be a 100%, Tyler.
Yeah. You'd win every block though.
Yeah. There you go. I I I don't wanna leave it up to a chance.
A 100 a 100 x a hash, just, you know, throwing a round number out there. If we had a 100 x a hash pointed to us, on average, you should get a block every two hours. So that that would be that would work. Mhmm. So we need a 100 x a hash. Paolo, if you're listening, 100 x a hash
for just to be safe, eight hours. Because we're doing it from twelve to seven. So seven hours. Would 25 x a hash put you right at that eight hour mark?
Let's see. Yeah. But
You don't wanna chance it. Yeah. We don't wanna change This is six hours. You know? Six hours? Okay.
Yeah. Or Geon. A 100 hash would just matching matching donation. Yeah.
With big deal. I mean, he's got some Who's gonna contribute more? You.
Yeah.
Yeah. What what is what did he send? Who wants to Who's the top dog? You know? Who's the top dog? Send him a DM. Look.
Yeah. Actually, honestly, Iko, seriously, will will you
can you send him the DM?
You want him to do the DM? Yeah. DM. DM
him. Be like, hey. Look. Send them the clip of us hitting the block and be like, look. Here, just if you wanna point some hash, if you wanna go, you know, we're looking for minimum 10 x a hash, didn't stutter,
point it here.
They, you know, they
Jiangmu is running BitDeer now, and they are a very large miner. Right? They run a lot of their own machines. Actually,
think the whole farm. You know? Let me send somebody a DM real quick. How much hash rate could we get if we get all of the basic manufacturers to point us their break in period from the factory?
Yeah. Just the break in period. That's it. No big deal.
Bit dear. I think yeah. I have the The break in period lasts till they, like, have the next generation
ready to start breaking in. And then they start selling the one that they just broke in.
There's like an area 51 of miners that are already at 2 jewels per terahash.
Yeah. We need to think yeah. Go on. Me to, I will I will DM
Jihan Wu
and send him the link to the video of us finding the block
last year and
or in January.
So we don't do any pay for play on pod 56.
With that said,
if he does donate and he would like an invitation to come on the pod ahead of time,
we'd we'd love to invite him on the pod.
Okay. May even without the donation, unrelated, actually, just come on the pod. We can discuss it. And how about we point the hash live on air? That would be actually pretty dope too.
Let me open up the
I gotta work with Steve Myers to open up a port here on the Bitcoin Park router publicly Mhmm.
To get Hashrate to come into this server I've got.
Yeah. Actually, we should start testing that out anyways.
Well, yeah. I mean, I gotta I'm working with Jungly. We're we're getting there. Okay. But yeah. Let me Two weeks Turkish?
No. It should be, like,
right right after the the holiday here. So in the next few days.
Cool.
Yeah. You gotta hurry up, Iko. Mine's mine's public. What the hell, man? Yeah. I know. But you've got see, that's the thing. You're
I have a Jeff Bride.
Yeah. You've
just got, like, unrestricted access to all that stuff. I can't access the Bitcoin park router.
Wait. Why can't you?
Because you didn't give me the password.
Okay. I'll we'll solve that.
I don't It's still 1234. It's fine.
You know, I don't think you want me messing around with the router.
Okay. No. It's I think it's you're you're doing the right thing having, like, dedicated people who have access to it.
You don't want too many cooks in the kitchen. That's true. Whenever our Internet goes down, I get blamed. Yeah. And it's
it's not like this is being held up because I don't have access to the router. It's just Copy. You know?
I I've still got an update I need to do, and I need to work with Jungly on that, and then and then I'll be ready to to do it. So
Cool. Alright. So we got Steve has been very responsive. No. Steve's the best, seriously. Like,
protect Steve at all costs. 10
to 50 exahash
from
Gihan,
10 to 50 from Palo.
So
we're at, like, a 100. Why don't we just here's an idea. Why don't we just ask
all the ASIC manufacturers?
Yeah. Yeah. Shoot them shoot your shot, king.
Let's go.
Scott Scott was the best.
Scott, just ask Bitmain.
Well, you gotta I have a I have a clear communication regular meetings with Bitmain. So Right. I'll just toss that out there when I'm talking to them like I normally do. Mhmm.
That would be so dope.
That would be dope. That would be like, just getting that hash rate up. But but, yes. Like, we should we should
do, a pop up telehash or or maybe pre launch the telehash so that people could start pointing hash rate ahead of time. Right? So it doesn't have to, like, quote, unquote, start at 12:00 on the twenty first.
Yeah. So I'm gonna once I open this up to the public, I'll that'll go out on social media, and I'm gonna start asking all the hashers who've been pointing Hashrate to pod
two fifty six accounts,
like Ocean and CK Pool and LingQoin
to start migrating those over to this,
HydroPool server that we're running. And then we're gonna I'm just gonna leave that up and, you know, try to maintain it the best I can,
and,
and we'll leave it up. It's I should clarify.
It is not the intention of the two fifty six foundation
to run a public
mining pool Yeah. For everybody. This this
hydro pool instance that I'm hosting
will be configured in such a way that in the event a block is found,
100% of that is going to go to the two fifty six foundations. Yeah. So it's not you know, if you're pointing hash rate
to that pool, it's because you want to support the two fifty six foundation
and help us, you know, play the lottery. If you imagine,
some dude was like, hey.
Yeah. I just just to clarify. That's a good clarification,
honestly, because there's a lot of artists out there that'll be like, no. I didn't hear your share.
Where's my share? Yeah.
But the great thing is, HYDRApool is super simple to spin up if you want to run your own instance,
and we designed it that way. And there's even a step by step guide you can follow at hydrapool.org.
So
run your own hydro pool and invite all your friends in your community
to join you there.
And you can have total control on on how the Coinbase reward is split up.
That's so cool.
So cool. I know, Tyler, you actually said it really well. It's like the it it it feels like it's already out there. Right? All these different pieces, and we've opened up the the the closed box.
And now we're just, like, starting the tinkering and showing
what is what is possible.
And I think just twin 26 is gonna be
pretty, pretty epic. Well, yeah, we're gonna we're gonna get a more polished Regina.
Mhmm.
Ember one with the Intel chips. Right?
Me? You yeah. With me. With me.
Hydro pool, more polished more polished Sure. Interface, more polished back end,
more
app
what's the word? Is it extensibility?
Like, making it able to
have, like, different payout
Mhmm. Schemes if people want, like, maybe even some integration
into the,
the, like, e hash
Mhmm.
E cash token.
Help me out here, Scott.
Yeah.
It's it's a payout scheme using,
eCash,
from,
VMPRC.
Yeah. Is that Evan's thing? New idea. Yeah. Evan. Hashpool is it called or no? That's it. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
Hashpool.
But, yeah, I mean, that's that's
in my mind, one of the really cool things about having a an open source firmware,
that's that's, you know, modular is that you can just try these things out. Like, you have a new idea, you have something you've always wanted to try, like,
this is where you try it out and Mhmm. You know, improve on it and and prove it.
I think we're gonna see the floodgates open here. Yeah. And that's where the momentum builds too.
Just sorry. Because outside of the core pillars, these core projects
that will have maintainers,
fingers crossed, for for the foreseeable future. Right?
You could say, you know what? I'm gonna make this my jam to make sure that the water block or the heat sink or the reference chassis or whatever, you can kinda come in and just keep improving, and no one's holding you back. Yeah. Totally. All the resources are there.
I feel like we've seen we we oh, sorry. Go ahead.
Oh, no. Go ahead.
Oh, I just I think we've seen, you know, from the the heat punks and and lots of different facets, like, people want to be working on this. Like, they have ideas, and they wanna try things. Like, the whole Loki rig thing started by, Zach Bombster.
You know, we just saw this this huge,
group of people that wanna tinker with stuff, they wanna play and
and build things, and they have fantastic ideas.
But I think they're being held back by proprietary stuff,
know, an ecosystem that doesn't really want them.
So I I hope we can
we can, you know, help all those guys build things faster and better and then all the other people that have just been on the edge wanting to get in,
can really just go nuts in in 2026.
Yeah.
Well said.
Yeah. That's one of my goals for Mugena is to,
you know, do some evangelization,
encourage
people, do some videos.
Yeah. Hell yeah. You know, get people contributing
because
it's easy.
And with with the like we talked about with the bid acts, you can get started today.
And just to prove the point,
within the last couple weeks,
a Bitcoin veteran
contributed a preliminary
integration of
Stratum v two
into Mugena.
No way.
And I saw a demo of it work working. Let's go. Woah.
Wow. So that's that's in a branch cool is that? In the Mugena
repo today.
So That's awesome. Just just to prove the point, like, yeah, this stuff being open and can easily
accessible,
the invitations out there to
come work on that.
That's exactly what we wanted to enable, right? People can just work on Then scratch their itch and
contribute it for to everybody else.
Like, Strata v two has been around for so long. Yeah. And I guess we've seen we've seen two different miners,
brains,
and now just recently,
Aradine Yeah. Have integrated it, but it it took forever. Right? Mean, StrandV two more or less has been around for years,
and it's taken them so long to get it integrated. And now here we have Mugena, and it's like contributed
an SV2
plugin. Like Yeah. This is gonna accelerate these these cool new technologies so fast. Like,
y'all aren't even ready for how cool this is gonna be. That's awesome.
It's true. We already have a beta of Mugena in Home Assistant to make it so you can control it with your IoT devices.
Really? Yeah.
And it's a pain in the ass to do all this with all the various other jailbreak firmwares or
OEM ones, or you don't know which versions are incompatible, what they change version over version.
There's no dev fee.
Yep.
How awesome is that?
Yeah. I've talked to miners,
like large miners and they're like, you know, a 2% dev fee is a non starter. Like, we have so many miners. Like, we are not gonna pay a 2% dev fee. And they they've gone down the route of, well, guess we have to make our own firmware.
You know? That's cheaper and in our our eyes better than paying a 2% dev fee. Is that But now look, you can take Mugena Yeah. And you can just start on that and you can get going
so much faster. Yeah.
I know. I feel like Mugena,
and of course Ryan's here for this, is like the I mean, all the other projects are super dope, but that one feels like it's solving
a financial
pain. Right? Or a major pain that we need to just go dig in to a lot a lot of these
bigger, more established mining
farms.
And then it's like, well, how do we contribute back? It's like
money to the two six foundation to, like, you know, continue to support this. Yeah. Like, that's it. Like, okay. So 2%, how about point 2%
and, you know, pay that out to the two two six foundation? What would that mean? Or point 02%.
I don't know what that
That's a good point. The Anything Regina bottleneck. With one block find.
Yeah.
That we'll we'll go I mean, I'll go to you, Tyler, in a second. One of my things that I was, like, I I was never nervous,
but, like, you know, hitting the block, we had all this money. It was, like, way a lot of money. Like, 3.14
Bitcoin was, like, a lot. And every time, I was like, alright. Ryan, like, you know, it was, like, really getting to people.
And every time I I think I when I was, like, talking with each of the individuals, I'm like, hey, man.
Like,
don't fuck this up, please, for me. Just like, you gotta ship this. You know? Like, what's your confidence level shipping this, like, way within this, like, period of time? Because there's one thing we give you this grant, and then there's another thing of, like, not shipping it, or there's, like, scope creep where you get burned. And, like, whatever. I'm like, do you have the stamina, and can you get this done within this period of time? Like, the money's gonna come. And I'm I was pretty proud. Like, we were consistent with our payouts, and everything was, like, pretty clockwork,
on that end on the back end. But, like, you guys, every single one of you guys delivered, and it was so freaking cool.
Yeah. I can't wait to show it all off on,
January
at the third
telehash.
The third tell yeah. That's crazy. Yeah. Yeah. Can I reanswer the question you asked me a while ago? You said what's what's it been like to work on Mugena or whatever this year? I think my reanswer would be
what a great group of people you assembled.
Like, that's what it's like to work. I mean, this is just a great group.
Each one of them I'm not gonna say me. Each one of them really know what they're doing. Yeah. Totally.
And are really cool people to work with. So, yeah, this is there's there's no duds here. This has been a real,
whole is greater than the sum of its parts kind of
experience.
Totally. And I'm I'm gonna boost his ego again,
but, like, this would not be possible without, like, Eko
to be in, like, the technical PM, keeping everybody like, hey, guys. We got the call the weekly call. Hey, guys. We're just all the checkpoints, all the tests, all all the things
that are way above my pay grade. And it was just like, dude, we got the Avengers assembled. We now need more Avengers.
We need a little bit more support
behind it. And then this thing, you know and, of course, it's gonna be Ji Han Woo that freaking provides the most support and then takes us to the next level.
Just
joking.
But,
yeah, we'll see what happens. It does feel super rewarding to just play a small part of this. I mean, you guys ever think you would
especially for the guys that might have seen it in in earlier years with, you know, general purpose personal computing or the Internet era, like,
just this quirky nature of an emerging industry.
Scott, you talk about this well, so do you, Ryan, where things try to get closed down, people try to make certain things proprietary,
and at the end, the open source movement wins, the community wins, and it's like you get to relive that and be a part of it in the trenches. It's crazy.
I, yeah, pinch myself every morning.
It real dude, it really is. So, yo, I I was just looking at my calendar. I I we got
when's the next Wednesday? I I just closed it off. I want in on each of the next
pod two fifty six because I want once we open up the port for
HydroPool, I wanna start getting hash rate pointed that way, like, now. Let's go.
Because hey. Welcome back.
Hey. You know? Like, you know, I don't wanna be a flake and, you know, say I'm gonna be all the time back. But, like, leading up to the telehash, even though next week, I'm gonna be able to make it, I just looked out of the country.
Get out of here.
Oh, Paul always gonna save a beat for you. There he is. Thank you. Thank you. But I depending on the time, I'm gonna see if I could carve it out.
But
with that said, like, let's let's, like, show this. Like, Ryan, you you touched on this. I do think now
we're in the
we've done the work. Now we need to
and so there's this one line. I forget who who told me that, like, one of these CEOs, but, like, a lack of communication is a lack of performance.
And so now is the time for us to communicate all of the great work we've done. You mentioned doing tutorial videos, going on podcast, going speaking, and showing it. So one of the things we're gonna do at the park is
host more minor specific meetups and workshops
so that we could actually showcase this off whether that's in Austin or Nashville. Probably, you're gonna do it in in Denver as well.
Tyler and other other meetups are gonna do them as well. We're gonna do Grassroots Bitcoin in April.
So hopefully, Eco will be able to equip a lot of these meetup organizers as well so that they can be running this on their own. Scott, you're definitely welcome to come
to that too.
So I think this is like the kind of proof of show year for us
and
very, very bullish on this.
I think, you know, I think this is gonna happen, but I think we can we can help, incubate it. But normalize being a Bitcoin miner developer. Like Yeah. You know, there's lots of developers out there. Yeah. Previously,
it's been so closed off. If you want to get involved, it was very difficult. But I think one of the things we're starting here is this this ecosystem
where, you know, if you are interested,
you can jump in and be a part of this. And it's a growing community
of people that are building rad stuff. Like,
I think
getting more developers in on this, the excitement, the fame, the fortune, yeah, all of that, like All of it. No. You can you can get in on this. So
I love this idea that you kinda put in my head. Like, we had a call on Monday or the year of review, which is, like, this conf two fifty six idea,
which is, like, a Bitcoin mining development
conference.
You know? Like, just, like,
one day, two days of just, like, intense, like,
bring your tool belt, and let's go to work and show off, like, what we're building and working on together.
To, like, kinda see that as, an idea, dude, if you guys, like Ryan, Schnitzel,
Jung Lee, Scott, Tyler, Ico,
I think I've already made a comp code for Eko to use with some specific folks. But if there's some specific Bitcoin mining developers
that just want to come to the Telehash is free and open, so you can come to that. I mean, we'll probably have a cap on number of people,
but
but I'll I'll carve out a few tickets for NEMs,
and we'll get provide, like, two of these six foundation could provide a comp ticket for the I mean, the park will provide a comp ticket, so there's no, like, monetary
transaction there.
Because it would be cool to get more people
there for sure. For sure. It's such a good point too. I mean, mining development
for the past decade has felt like
a DARPA project that you know nothing about, And then something just shows up. You gotta buy it through some reseller on Telegram. Like, it's bullshit. Right? And now
the building blocks are there. You can be a part of it all the way down to the technical level for sure.
Dude,
and just, like,
there's just so much opportunity too. Because, like, I'm randomly
meeting with these university
presidents
and talking to them about, like, different
type of hackathons and case competitions
and so on. But the miner is the, like, the gateway drug for these kids too. Like, for them just to see that miner working in real life, touching and feeling it, and then learning all the intricacies of, like, running your own node. Like, what does it mean to miner block? Like, all of those things.
There's something there that I think over time, especially as we're consistent in our
proof of show and proof of work of
demonstrating the value,
I think, can go a long way. And then equipping these dude, these kids are super brilliant, like, and super sharp. Like, the more those folks are empowered and, like,
game on.
Yeah. Definitely. Totally do a class with a laptop and a BitX,
you know, hack on Mugena live. You can iterate so fast. You know? It's
that'd be so much fun. Yeah.
I
yeah. Yeah. We could do something like that. And now it's like the next thing is just, like, getting this out there into the mainstream so so that and there's even more of these foundations that wanna support,
FOS generally.
So what what was our hack on the what was it? DAFs? Donor advised funds. Yeah. We need to get those dollars, buddy. Like, yo. Hey. Rich people. I know you're listening.
You
got a DAF. I know you do. Call your banker, family office, whatever.
Put some of that DAF money towards the two fifty six foundation, two five six foundation. Just go into the drop down, hit send money, and let's go.
Easy.
We gotta get on the list, though.
I I thought we're on the list. For, I think for Onchain Capital, we're on the list.
Okay. But then, like, each, like, financial institutions got their list of We're on Fidelity's list, though. I know that. Right?
No. We're try I think we that's what we were talking about on Monday was getting on that list.
Okay. I thought somebody sent us money from the oh, maybe it was unchanged. Sound advisory one. Okay. We got we got two, like, totally random checks in the mail.
Yeah.
For And I'm cool with that. They were,
like
I can just imagine somebody's eyes are lighting up and hearing that. It was, like, they were both less than $25.
So, like, don't don't get too excited.
They
but, yeah, those came in from you know, the two fifty six foundation is on somebody's DAF list. I I I know Unchained is one, I believe.
I don't know where else they found
that information, though. Because it's not like we proactively
approached somebody and asked to be put on the list. Like, somebody put us on that list.
Mhmm. So I don't I don't know enough about that world.
But
Tyler Tyler, to foreshadow a little bit, I think Tyler is gonna be really going into it in the next starting January 1 as well as leading into next year. He's gonna crush it. He's that's why you shaved the the beard. Honestly
because I gotta ask people for money. Because you're gonna ask people for money, you know? Be like, hey. Look at me. Poor kid, you know, barely out of college. Me familia.
Me familia. It's it's the best. It works all the time. By
the way, you did crush your
Imagine If presentation.
And, honestly, like, there's, like,
three touch points. Eco, you did a good job too. Don't worry. Even if there if if there's a conspiracy theory against you.
But
The conspiracy theory is against you.
Oh, against me. Got it. Got it.
Where are you going with this?
What I'm saying is there's gonna be multiple touch points. So we got one in January. We have the Texas Energy Mining Summit. It's gonna be announced May,
and then ImagineIF coming
back. So I think all three of those, I always wanna incorporate the two to the six foundation
for folks that
wanna learn and and support
the the foundation
that you guys, you know, always have an open invite to to be involved
in in there. So
it's our my personal small way of continuing to help support
the two d six foundation and really
platforming and and putting what all the great work you guys are doing out there.
Well, thank you. And the cool part to me is we can meet people where they're at too. I have an idea stuck in my head that you mentioned, Rod, which is like the the large players, they're going to care most about the dev fee, Mugena, right? They don't necessarily care about a reference design of some 100 watt hash board, I don't think. No.
They don't really care about whatever chips you have on it because it's not the bleeding edge.
But
the Mugena dev fee is a huge bottleneck for them. Whereas on the other side of things, the Tinkerers and the Plebs and the Heatpunks, it's like,
I got to tear this thing apart just to rebuild it into something I want. And that's where, you know, the modifiable Ember one hash board is super useful to them. Or all these cool ass, like desktop toys, like the Nerd QX plus plus like having LibreBoard and be able to strap the biggest screen and LED lights, whatever the hell you want to it, it's going to unlock the world for them. That's really cool, where it works for everyone.
Oh, yeah. We
were going to make a miner that self destructs when it hits a block. We can do that now.
Holy smokes. Like, how would it smell self destruct?
I don't know. Explosives?
No. No. Seriously.
Like, I don't want a bomb going off in the middle of the night and bounce house. Fireworks.
Well, they make those, like Do we just kicked off this episode with fire.
They
they make those like those like server kill switch devices that you like mount in your computer that like incinerate it. I think it's Yeah. Uses Tannerite or some mixture.
Or like
the cold cards where it has the secure element and it says shoot here and you do that and like a gun shoots the hash board or something after it wins. That'd be cool. That'd be cool. We'll just overclock it to the max, remove the thermal temperature shutdown, and just go for glory. Like, just That'd
be awesome.
Iko, before I'd be remiss
before I roll.
Keon's
written a couple letters.
Yep. If you wanna provide an update. Yeah. Thanks.
So, yeah, Keoni is
I think he's on day number thirteen,
fourteen. So he's he's been in in prison now for almost two weeks.
He has a contact at The Rage,
which is a,
journalist outlet,
run by Lola Leets.
And you can find two letters that Keoni has published from prison
so far. It's looking like he's gonna be able to do that on a regular basis. So Nice. Keep an eye out for those.
Bill is scheduled to surrender to the Bureau of Prisons
in two days on Friday, January 2.
So
that's
you know, software developers should not be going to prison. Code is not crime.
There's a petition circulating to help garner support
to pardon the Samurai Wallet developers.
If you could please visit change.org/billandchioni
and
sign that petition and share the petition to get the message across to Donald Trump and the administration
that,
you would like to see the developers pardoned
because
software developers should not be responsible for end user conduct.
And
one last note, if you would like to make a financial contribution
to support the families
in the wake of this complete financial ruin that they have been dragged through,
you can find a fundraiser at givesendgo.com/billandchioni.
And there, you can make a donation in fiat that'll go 50% to both families.
After Bill's surrender date, we are gonna bring online,
cryptocurrency
donation options. So if you've got if you wanna make that donation
using cryptocurrency,
there will be options coming online soon.
13,555,
signatures.
100 k by telehash day. 100 k by Telehash day.
That would be great. Let's go. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, we're the way I look at it is Donate a hash.
Donate a signature.
Yeah. We're 13 and Well, maybe not that. The way there.
Maybe one x to hash, one I gotta figure out the math. But yes.
The the important thing is that it's it we just keep signing and sharing and keep the message alive.
Totally. The message that yeah. And I gotta give you credit there, man. You really took it from the beginning when it was nobody really talking about this, and you just were so consistent, Eko. I know you're close with them too, and
it's just been amazing. Well, it's been amazing to see the support. It's not amazing the outcome.
Mhmm. And Right. Like, hopeful hopefully, there's a quality outcome in the near future. Yeah. Let's hope so. These guys shouldn't be sitting in prison.
Yeah.
Before we
wrap it up on this sort of hundredth anniversary episode,
I would love to hear from you, Rod. Like, how did this get started? Like, this podcast changed my life,
you guys.
How how did this happen? Like, how did this come together?
Well,
Iko, what was the name of your podcast that you were doing by yourself again? So all through 2022,
I was hosting my own video
podcast
called
the Hashcast.
That's right.
And It was so amazing. Every every,
difficulty adjustment, Eco would come out with a podcast.
Yeah. So, like, every, like, roughly every two weeks, I would record a new podcast and go over the state of the network
and news items
and, know, anything I thought was interesting about mining.
I very rarely had any guests on the show, but there were a few episodes where I had guests on.
And,
you know, toward the 2022,
like, I
really needed to spend my time,
making money
instead of screwing around with the podcast.
So I was, like, I was shutting down the Hashcast. I'm like, okay. Like, 2022,
Hashcast is over. I don't have time for it. It's been fun, everybody.
I'll see you later. And I was, you know, getting ready to to spend all my time and energy doing other things.
And,
apparently,
Rod was the HashCast biggest fan
and was, like, watching every episode.
And so he reached out to Facts.
Yeah. And he reached out to me and was like, dude, you can't
you can't stop doing this. You have to keep doing this. And and that's that's when we started
talking.
Well yeah. And he was like, look. It just takes too much I mean, in
in perfect
now knowing Ego for now a number of years and working with him, he is unbelievably
meticulous and detail oriented, and he wants to do, like, a plus work all the freaking time. That's what I love about him. So he's like, Rod, this is what I do with the the podcast. I do this and do that, and then blah blah blah blah, all the details. I'm like, okay. What if I could extrapolate
away 80 to 85% of the production and distribute like, all that stuff.
And then you just show up, and I'll do it with you, and we'll see how it goes.
And you're like, okay. Let's just see how it goes. And then next and by the way, before
prod two d six, you were soliciting donations through people asking people to point you a hash rate for the HashCast.
Right?
I Or no? Can't recall if I was or I might have.
I think I thought you did or maybe
yeah. I think you did, man. Because, like well,
you thought of that ingenious idea
and
and made it happen.
So Yeah. I I don't know when
I don't know if that was, like, after we started pod February or or if it if that was an idea that
I came up with on the HashCast. But But you had the the the format was pretty much in, like, the state of the network. Like, all of the those things were from the HashCast.
Yeah. And we're basically like, alright. Let's roll. And then we we invited some guests. Then, you know, Scott came along, and I was like, dude, he's gotta be a mainstay. He's a legend. And, you know, we're like, Scott keep coming. We just kept on sending him calendar invites to come to the next one come to the next one. Like like, early twenty twenty three is around the time I,
you know, the Bidax got on my radar.
Right? Like
because when when did the Bidax project start taking off?
You know, I had been working on it just kinda here and there, but I think it was sort of maybe mid twenty twenty three. It started being a thing that actually kinda worked.
Yeah. I I just I remember I think that's right. I remember seeing it and being like, dude, we gotta get, Rod. We gotta get this guy on the podcast to
talk to him. Like, he's doing some really interesting work. I forget what number episode that was. We should go look back on. Your first pod two fifty six appearance. But
I I had been listening. I was like, this is amazing. These guys are just talking about what all I wanna talk about all day. It
was fantastic to listen to. And then
out of the blue, I think it was on Twitter, I get a message from Rod,
and he's like, you wanna dress? I'm like, oh my god. You're kidding me. No. That's so cool, man. You you know, like, that
and it was actually kind of funny because, again, like, similar to EcoProbably, I was just like a one off podcast. I was like, never thought much of it.
And then I forget where I was. Maybe it was at NEMs or where maybe it was at the and then, like, Eric from Gridless Compute was like, dude, I listened to every single one of these. Like, I'm coming to the that one blew my mind. He's like, I'm coming to the Nashville Energy Mining Summit because of, like, what you guys are talking about. And this was, like,
'24.
Yeah. I wanna say. And I'm like, dude, you're flying from Nairobi, Kenya
to Nashville's gonna be cold as shit. Like, what the you don't wanna be coming. Oh, I'm like, alright. Come on. And then I was like, woah. Eco, it really
you know, we joke about the two to 10,000,000, but honestly, every single person that's listening is an absolute stud and legend, and we're so thankful. Because you gotta be, like, kinda
well, you definitely gotta be into what we're
doing,
but you also gotta understand our humor a little bit as well. So it's like a really specific person. So there's maybe two people in the world, Eric and Scott. But besides that,
you know, it's awesome.
So yeah. Then that's that's what happened, and the next thing you know,
ECO also again was like, man, we gotta dismantle this proprietary Bitcoin mining empire. I'm like, man, I got, like, 16 kids right now. Like, I don't know if I got time for that, but
let's see what we can do.
Well and I think
I think it actually started with a episode we did with Schnitzel.
Mhmm. And and we were, like, talking about, like, starting a business and then getting the
like, having a
public charity
so that people could donate to the developers to have the developers
build the
open source tech
that would, like, then, like, support the businesses on top of it. Right? Yep. And,
like, I think it it was out of that conversation we were like, should we should we start
a nonprofit? Like
and there were just so many reasons why it it made sense.
And it it seemed like it wasn't, like, that unreasonable
of a lift to do. Like, it it has No. Just the documentation is kind of annoying. But, like, other than that tedious. Yeah. Yeah. But but you've handled it and managed it all, so, like, kudos to you on that.
Yeah. Didn't the bunker almost turn into a lab? I remember hearing about that on an old episode. Dude, damn, Rod. Go
ahead. No. No. No. Go lore on that. Well, Rod and I went and toured a bunker. We were looking for a Eco is like, we're a 100% getting this place. I'm like, no way. We're getting this place. Dude, I wanted to was wild. So bad. That bunker We'll find another reason to get it.
Dude, it was actually super wild. I mean, it was a legit bunker. Like Yeah. Straight up.
I I forget year. I forget which agency
built the bunker originally,
but it was it was where, like, the Tennessee governor would go in the event of nuclear warfare
Yeah. Yeah. For, you know, several years from Eighty years ago. Yeah. Yeah. Like,
I think the bunker was originally built in, like, the fifties or sixties.
Yeah. So, like, it was old and outdated. Like, don't get me wrong, but it was, like, a legit ass bunker. Like That's awesome.
Concrete walls
buried in the side of a mountain.
Like,
it was something else.
Yeah. It seems highly necessary
Yeah. I see. When we get the right amount of donation.
Yeah. It had, like, all the old, like, air scrubber system in it to, like, get all the fallout out of the air.
Here's the deal. Exergy becomes a a billion dollar plus revenue company.
Exergy
buys and donates a bunker to the two fifty six Foundation. There we go.
Or an old console silo or something. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Something like that.
We're we're counting on you, Tyler. Okay.
I'll try.
Yeah, those old episodes, that was awesome. I mean, remember hearing the story
when it was just an idea, a foundation,
transforming to what it is now, and now having hardware and software in this world. It's crazy.
Yeah, it really is crazy. This
is why I look at other entrepreneurs and other people. I'm like, dude, if, like, a knucklehead like me and a really smart person like Eco can do this, like,
honestly,
they're like, nothing is impossible.
You just need to do it. And so and Ryan made a good point. Like, surrounding yourself by amazing people
and also working in a
industry that has, like, a good amount of, like, natural growth. Like, every day, there are more Bitcoiners.
Every day, more people are waking up to freedom technology. And being like, wait. Why am I putting all this information into this, like, centralized AI? Shouldn't I be like, thinking about, I hope, their
how they're using
their own personal data. And then all of a sudden, get, like,
these people like Nebula that are like, hey, man. I am, like, twenty years experience into this one specific area. Here's how I can help. And then you're adding all these building blocks, and you just see something come together. It just it's it blows my mind.
Yeah.
Rod, you you
also, though,
I remember at my first NEMs
twenty twenty four, it was the winter storm one.
Something like, don't quit your job. All these knuckleheads, don't quit your job to come work Bitcoin. And I was too thick skulled. I was like,
fuck this guy. I'm gonna do it anyway. So what's your current stance on that? Let's go.
No. So my my and just to give some more context on that Please. Which is a lot of these guys are making a very good amount of money in their, you know, fiat job.
And it's like, don't just, like, willy nilly just cold turkey quit it without, like, having something that you're super passionate about or build. You can build at night and but stack as much Bitcoin as humanly possible
to give yourself even more of a runway such that you could take that risk and so on.
So because, like, a lot of these guys may yeah. They may not love their job, but it's still a very good job and making some good money while you're building a network, you're building a skill set, you're building all these things.
My point there is just like, all of a sudden, your your wealth goes from, you know, you had 1 Bitcoin, and it was, like, 10,000, and then it goes to a 100,000. And you're yep. You know what? That's my number. I'm I'm done. It's like, not really, buddy. Like, you know, because that number goes back down to 40 or 30 or whatever, and it's like, oh, shit. I gotta go back to the job I just told them to fuck off at now because I really need to flip I guess I'm gonna go flip burgers now. So it's like, that's my point is, like, definitely be an entrepreneur at least once in your life for sure because that is
the coolest, also the most
exhilarating
experience you'll have because asking somebody or providing value such that someone is paying you for that value
is pretty amazing.
And then yeah. And and keep going. So
I would just say, rather than just telling everybody to get into Bitcoin and then by the way, also the Bitcoin jobs out there pay, like, half compared to Mhmm. Any of the other jobs out there just because the businesses are so new, the margins are not there, and it's just it's not there. So and I and at the end of the day, keep your Fiat job, go and volunteer at, like, a meetup or start your meetup and go get your fix in there, and then figure out
like, for you, it was an easier decision because you knew exactly kind of where you wanted to be Mhmm. And what part of the stack. Like, mining was so interesting to you, and you're like, I'm gonna go deep into this area.
And I will say, which is counter to, like, what I was just saying, like, you do at some point wanna just burn all boats and say, alright. Well, burning all the boats, I'm just gonna figure this out. Alright. More power to you. That's what, like, honestly, Jack and Andrew did, and I told them not to quit their jobs to come work with me at Bitcoin Park because I was like, dude, like, just don't do that. And they're like, alright. Well, I'm doing it anyways whether you hire me or not. I'm like, fuck. That's, I think, the common story. It's always that same story, though.
Yeah. It's the people that do it anyways.
Yes. Yeah. And and respect to them. You know? I just I don't wanna be the guy that's like, well, Rod told me to quit my job.
That's true.
Know? It's like, no. Rod told you to not do this.
And I'd I you know, that actually makes a good point. I'd rather be the guy that I told not to do it, and then they have such a chip on their shoulder, and they, like, print out a photo of me and be like, fuck that guy. I'm gonna prove him wrong. They're like, cool. Good for you.
Yeah.
Good memories.
But
this is you know, it'll be cool because this is year well, we've been doing this for a while, but, like, technically,
we'll
do, like, pre block, post block.
Year this will be year two of post block,
and,
it's gonna be really, really cool to see see what happens,
in 2026.
And
I couldn't be more honored and, thankful to be working with you guys on this.
Likewise.
Likewise. 100%.
It'll be fun. Hopefully, we kick 2026
off to a great start with the telehash.
Thank you. What
I'll I'll I'll say it now, and then we can come in a year and and see if this works out. What's the probability that Gi hun either
contributes Bitcoin
or
contributes,
resources
to the two fifty six foundation?
I'd give it a
like, on a scale from zero to one, like, a point seven five probability.
That's 75%.
Right? Yeah. I think so. Isn't that how probabilities work?
Well, how about this? Let's simplify it. Let's make it rod retarded.
0%
to a 100%.
Where where are you on that scale? Yeah. 75%.
Wow. Wow.
That's a wow. I think following the account is a pretty explicit thing to do. No. Iko's been DM ing with him that day. He's having conversations
that are we are not privy to. That's why
I mean, it just accidentally
hit the follow button when he was scrolling.
No.
No. This is
Jihon Woo is not a man. He's like, I followed who? What?
Keystrokes.
Yeah. That's right. Alright. Tyler, what's your probability?
I don't know about 75,
but I do think it's above 50. I'll say I
think it's a deliberate action to follow the two five six foundation.
Okay. Ryan?
Oh,
I'm gonna take the under.
I'll
go 2%.
Yeah. Oh, okay. 2%. Ryan thinks all of the 3,140
followers are keystroke accidents. Except
for two percent of them.
What about you, Scott?
I was thinking of the Dumb and Dumber,
like,
so you're telling me there's a chance. Yeah. I love that line.
What so what's I see. What's your probability?
Well, the the
I think Eric from Goodlist, he made a or no. It was Josh. Beefsteak Josh set this really neat it's like the Han Solo. It's like, don't tell me the odds.
Oh, yeah.
K.
So if if Gihan's one stipulation is just having dinner with you and just hashing it out, no pun intended, you you're down for that, Scott?
Oh, yeah. Definitely. I've got some questions.
Okay. Good. Good. Alright. I'm gonna go with 2.01%,
so just above Ryan to do the prices right. Yeah. The old prices right strategy.
Yeah. And
and then we'll see what happens. But
this has been super fun, guys. We're almost on two hours right now.
And I hopefully, I'm in bed by 08:30 like I normally am. And I know you guys are probably Tyler's definitely going out to party tonight. No way. I thought you and I were going down to Broadway.
No. That's not happening.
It is not happening.
I love Nashville, and we should you know, I'm I'm I'm very, on the zero tax train. However, if we need tax revenue to to support
some of these programs,
you know, consumption tax, especially around New Year's, have at it. Like, take up 75%
taxes on drinks, whatever downtown,
it doesn't matter. They're paying for it. Is that what it is? No. I'm making it up. But, like, honestly, if you think about it,
you think any of these people are gonna not come down to Broadway and not party down there? So if you just think about the consumption and the fleeting, you know, area, it's like sniping all those people that are coming into town
while boosting up our local purchasing power and make strengthening the so
anyways,
that's how Mayor Rod. No. Not happening. I knew that was gonna come up, so I I just cut myself off. There's zero chance on that. Wait. How does it boost our local purchasing power? The drinks are more expensive.
No. No. Just during that, like, New Year's period of time. Yeah. Exactly.
And also in just that one area of town, which is complete tourism. You know?
Everything is commercial down there now. It's not there's no, like, local. They they you know, they say there's some local bars, but, like, what loc I mean, at least the people I hang out with, there's no local that's like, hey. Let's go to a local bar on Broadway. It's like, hell no. We're gonna go, you know I'll go I'll go 2% on Mayor Rod.
No. Zero. I'll go zero, and I have a 100%
confirmation
on that. Yeah. Got Jihan Wu running me. This would be great.
Jihan's like, alright, Rod. I'm gonna fund you with a 10,000
event. Would you start a daycare?
Dude, we're we're gonna we're gonna have so many daycares. It's not even funny around Nashville. Did you see the Bitcoin bugle?
No. No. They
Oh, I yeah.
That was good.
Bitcoin
park is gonna get to daycares or something. Yeah. Oh, no way. Yeah. That was good. That was good.
It's genius. Yeah. It was funny.
Alright.
Gentlemen.
Okay.
It's been real. Happy New Year. We'll see you next year.
We'll see you next guys. Alright. Happy New Year. Cheers. Cheers, everyone.